hey chess friends national master james
canton iii here with chess.com and today
we have game of the day with the white
pieces we have stock fish
and with the black pieces leela chest
zero let's get right into it here
we go and we have e4 on the board and e6
of frenchie very solid but you also have
the french bishop which usually deters a
lot of players
which usually means this bishop gets
locked in behind the pawn chain
as opposed to the counterpart the cousin
of the french which is the caro khan
which locks the bishop outside the pawn
chain in most cases
so e46 d4 d5 very solid opening uh
choice from black here lead the chest
zero very solid and positional kind of
game you get from the french
knight to c3 one of the best ways to
play here you can go into a win hour you
can go into a normal classical variation
many things can happen from knight to c3
it is a sharp way of playing
and knight f6 actually from leela
chazilla here regular
chess here nothing nothing too too crazy
and after bishop g5
is all development here what you will
see usually is the bishop e7 move going
into the classical variation
of the french defense in this line i was
a fan favorite of this and after e5 you
have 94 and 97
which are main moves that humans play in
fact knight g8
doesn't feel that great actually i've
never actually seen this move to be
honest
and i've never played against this one
in fact this this variation is called
the
vista neckis variation of the french
i've never heard of it but knight to g8
makes total sense you want to take back
with tonight
in fact knight d7 is the usual here
going into the classical variation
after captures f4 and a6 stopping knight
b5 after c5
and it's a battle of who's getting to
the king first a lot of times in these
lines
so after e5 there's knight to ga getting
out of the way and instead of trading
they always say to take is a mistake
not all the time of course if it's free
and you're mating or something
definitely take that but to take as a
mistake you want to be asking yourself
does it help them
or does it help me more capturing in
fact it helps black out
where now he's able to just castle and
get the knight to f5 which is something
that's a main idea in the french defense
knight to g8 we just back it up bishop
e3
h5 to gain some space you also see g5 as
well
you also see something maybe like g6 or
knight h6
all these are possibilities very close
game
usually that's what happens in the
french defenses is a closed type of
nature here
where it's a lot of maneuvering and a
lot of uh piece play
and you also look for pawn breaks so in
closed positions it's all about those
two things really is maneuvering
and pawn breaks so whoever can maneuver
better and whoever can control the pawn
breaks which are things like
c5 pawn break meaning breaking up a pawn
chain or center so that would be the c5
move
or f4 f5 for white trying to break this
down whoever can control that can
control the game
but it is about maneuvering pieces so
take a look let's see what happens
h5 knight f3 developing b6 we would see
usually something like c5 but that
didn't happen here no problem
b6 is a very multi-purpose move what it
does is not only say maybe i put the
bishop on b7 but
usually you want to put it on a6 to
actually trade my terrible bishop
for your great bishop is the always the
idea here
where now my pawns are already on the
light squares and the rule is when you
trade a bishop
you usually want to if you're left with
a bishop after you trade a bishop
bishop you usually want to put the pawns
on the same color of the bishop that you
traded
especially if you are left with a bishop
so in this case
trading the light square bishop we want
to put our pawns on the light squares
because the dark square bishop will be
an absolute monster and we don't bump
into the pawns at all
so b6 a4 happens here just saying a5 you
also can play knight b5
a lot in these cases with bishop to a6
or even bishop b5 check
afterwards and put a pawn or a piece on
b5
a5 to follow and h4 looks kind of
strange
h4 a4 right but what it's doing is just
grabbing space
and sometimes you can even rook lift
rook h3 rook g3 if castling
put a bishop on d3 and slowly move the
king to f1 and g1 in that fashion
so h4 bishop a6 he says yeah let's get
those bishops off
and he says you know stockfish is like
hey just take it if you like
bishop b2 what do you do i'm just going
to get out of the way and have a nice
day pretty simple here still development
you could just immediately trade um you
could but also to take is a mistake
so if we would have taken on a6 we
helped the knight develop
or the rook and if if black takes on e2
we helped our queen get off the back
rank where our rooks
will be connected and i get to choose
which side to castle on says white
knight to h6 here and what happens in
these cases knight h6 is a move that
happens a lot in the french defense
knights on the rim are dim so what you
want to do if you ever put a knight on
the rim or the edge of the board
you need to within two moves move it
back to the center knight f5 being a
very strong possibility and again one of
the ideas of the french
also knight to g4 is a very strong nor
strong square as well
these are just holes in the position
that white has
so you want to take f5 or g4 in fact f5
is black square
being on the black's half of the board
and g4
is the light square being on the other
half of the board but both of these are
weak squares so we could put the knight
on one of them and just kind of chill
out
so what did white say not today bro we
got to get rid of those my guy
bishop takes knight and get rid of it
rook takes h6 and then g3
which is a very common move again in the
french defense it's a very slow type of
game
maneuvering peace play where do my
pieces best fit
trades in-game stuff very boring
sometimes
sometimes it's very boring sometimes
it's not but a lot of maneuvering
nothing just already just crushing these
are slower games so after g3
which sometimes prepares king f1 king g2
usually sit the king here a lot things
like that it's also a good waiting move
you defend h4
so g3 rick h80 goes back and says yeah
my rook's done enough
let's just go back home i don't have any
threats or targets so we're going to
play rook h8
king f1 and there it is threatening or
not threading but trying to go to king
g2 here in these cases hand castling by
hand
and sometimes even using the g pawn it
just depends on the game though but king
f1
bishop takes e2 and says it's time to
trade him queen takes and king f8
so we're sitting looking right at each
other as if we cast with literally a
file over here
but again this is a slow game so it
takes two steps hopefully pop quiz
what are the two things you need to do
in closed positions can you remember
what's number one hopefully you said
maneuvering and what's number two
pawn breaks that's correct great job
king f8 and then rook to d1
and rook to d1 so maybe something like
rook d3 try to get this knight to g5 but
again this is a maneuvering game you got
to be very clever
and you have to really do well thought
out plans when it comes to these type of
games
knight to c6 king to g2 now we have the
king here now we can do something like
rook f1 knight h2 f4 f5
his king sits here so we're trying to as
fast as possible get to it
king to g8 steps out of the way so now
the king's not there anymore so that's
not a thing
and then white says just knight b5 put
the knight on the square
and just try to gain some space it's not
any huge advantage here for either side
white does have a spatial advantage and
space is a big advantage why we have a
pawn on e5 in fact we're the only
only color here well the only engine
right now that's crossed the line and
what's the line one to four
and five to eight so white is in black's
territory and not the other way around
so we have a pawn on e5 and the knight
on b5 so
we could give a slight edge to whites
here definitely
so we just have to it's a squeeze it's
like a very slow methodical game is what
you're going to get here
so knight to b5 knight to b4 says the
same thing c6 could be in the air
and he plays knight to g1 what a move
knight to g1
maneuvering f4 knight h3 watch these
next maneuvers guys
knight a6 like what are they doing
you're like yo what is this game
what are we doing this is like i can
fall asleep almost
because there's so much just a night hop
night hop
night hop think about night hopping
again and some more night hops c3
c6 oh another night hop and another one
right they're doing the same thing night
before knight a6
nice nice c7 it's almost like a troll a
game in a way
knight b5 knight a3 knight c2 queen f3
and then um
sorry after uh after uh we see g6 and
then queen f3
g6 queen f3 and b5 so now black has made
a pawn break
number two right number one is
maneuvering look at all these maneuvers
they're doing
knight on g1 undeveloped and i don't see
two strange game but it is a closed game
very compact
very close center very tight so you need
pawn breaks you also want to have the
knights in these type of positions
and not the bishops because the bishop's
just what doing what yeah he's keeping
an eye on stuff but he's not doing
anything
he's going to just chill especially if
everything's locked up now if you open
the game
this bishop is gonna become a monster
but because it's close these knights are
the monsters right now until we can find
good squares we gotta find great squares
to put our pieces on b5 and then b3 here
very positional game to learn some
french defense
from both sides actually will be this
game right here pretty strong stuff
b3 and knight to e8 another knight move
here went from b4
to a6 to c7 to e8 i don't know where
he's going now maybe g7 f5
let's see knight h3 developing some more
maybe moving the queen over
and trying to even play g4 or g5 or
putting a knight on g5
following something like 91 knight f3
knight g7 there it is and we're going to
play knight f5
a takes b5 c takes b5 and c4
pawn breaks that's number two right
number one is the maneuvers we did a lot
of maneuvers
move the knight around handcastle put
the king on g2 black did the same thing
put the king on ga
how many times did this knight move
where did this knight come from right
it's on
g7 maneuvers and then number two is the
pawn breaks how many pawn breaks did we
see b5 being one
now white breaking with c4 but also
allowing white black to have a pass pawn
so this is very now it's dynamic once
this game opens up it could be nuts
let's see what happens c4
b takes c4 so this bishop is getting
stronger but it's not it doesn't have
any real targets so it's kind of hitting
air
in a way b takes c4 and b takes c4 and
then
knight f5 and we live he like finally we
can do something
i'm alive i can breathe knight at five
big boy move here
so now we want to see what happens on d
take c4 if d takes c4 you actually have
d5 here
or knight f4 which are both good moves
here just sacrificing the pawn
that's what we're doing here sometimes
you sacrifice a pawn for initiative
or something greater you even have
knight e3 here as well but um knight f5
was the move chosen by leela chest zero
and then we went 93 because we're trying
to get rid of your best piece
which is actually the knight on f5
knight takes c3 queen takes e3 now we
can easily play knight g5 or f4 steal
and try to figure out what to do with
these rooks too this is a pass pawn pass
pawns must be pushed and our worst piece
now is this knight sitting on h3
doing nothing d takes c4 and what do you
do in this position white to move of
course
kind of already saw this theme already d
take c4 but
what do you do
here it is guys d5 and we live very
simple
d5 if he takes d5 then of course we're
just going to see knight f4
which is very strong of course getting
the knight into play here into d5
hitting the bishop there's a hole here
on f6 oh it's going to be scary and this
is very weak
along with this yeah they're passed but
they i mean you're not going to queen
these it's going to be very difficult
to queen these uh much harder than you
you would think
so instead queen c8 was actually the
move keeping an eye here on this pawn
defending it maybe even queening and
also if we see d
takes e6 and there be queen takes e6 and
instead of taking with the pawn and
damaging my structure
queen to c8 and knight to f4 getting my
knight to a better square
because this knight was gross on h3 and
then king h7
kind of tucking the king activating the
h8 rook that still hasn't moved
queen f3 and rook g8 defending
d6 and now it's time to push these boys
past pawns must be pushed
bishop d8 and every piece that i own is
on the back rank
that's always usually a recipe for
disaster d7 and queen b8 and we great at
least we're feeling like it and now it's
right to move what would you do in this
position
you got lots of moves maybe rook c1 king
h2
rook b2 rhe1 i mean what else would you
do here
maybe move the knight 92 knight h3 what
would you do in this position
right to move
here it is i hope you're ready for this
i hope you're ready for this
here it is this is a family channel here
it goes
knight takes h5 let's do that again
knight takes h5
whoa knight takes h5 that's a big boy
move and now f7 is hanging
that's a piece now out of all this play
out of all this maneuvering
maneuvering finally we get to see
something
very spectacular which is knight takes
h5 and now we're hitting f7
h5 is hanging but there's still some
technique involved watch this
g takes h5 we take on f7 so now yes if
you look at compensation yes we sacked a
piece okay or you look at material
we sacked the piece so that's three
points he got a knight for we got one
pawn now we have a second pawn here
which is the f7 pawn
and now we have a third so in fact we're
actually even on material at this point
and we have some type of attack now we
do need multiple pieces for a successful
attack
usually three you could do it with two
sometimes but usually it takes three and
sometimes you count the pawn
as a piece when you're using the attacks
but here
we we only have what the queen right now
maybe the pawn
maybe but let's see what happens at
least we got our piece back
material wise three pawns queen takes h5
check king g8
and then we play rook d6 in the mix
trying to do something else we got to
get a rook
active we need more pieces to make this
king rook d6 rook
a6 like wait didn't you just block with
your face here
that's not a move big fella why did you
just do that rick takes a6 and
well actually you can resign now thanks
bro appreciate it hey man i
ate thanks for the generosity thank you
so much i appreciate you i'll vote for
you
right you know that's great queen b7
check now we're able to take
this rook that was the act of peace that
we needed to try to checkmate you
now white does have of course a
perpetual if things get really bad
like king g1 or king h2 and after takes
of the rook we could just
check check check back and forth
perpetual but you know we don't want a
perpetual here
instead we actually go instead of
instead of taking
we just move back rick d4 put a score
get about the way maybe bring the
work over to this side of the board c3
wow getting out of the way
of course and actually just trying to
push this pawn because we're trying to
clean and do whatever we can
and also bishop b6 is going to be coming
maybe queen b7 and what white does here
is actually just stepping out of the way
no checks i don't want any checks i
don't want any type of
you know oh this small little check
because especially a high level play and
engine play
like these strong engines are playing a
lot of times even the smallest move
will be game over due to calculation
king h2 is very nice stepping out of all
the checks a very nice prophylactic move
that of course the checks will be
annoying later so he steps out of it
kings too
after king h2 queen a7 hitting the rook
on f4
also x-raying and hitting the pawn on f2
through the rook on d4
queenie a check stepping out of the way
of course checking
uh you can't take this bishop the rook's
absolutely hanging king h7
and you check and you repeat and you
think you're going to take a draw here
right yeah just take a draw i mean why
not you know
just check back and forth i at least
have a draw here says stockfish but then
was the stockfish stinks for a little
bit
and just says well maybe we'll play on
just a little bit more rick gates to d1
defending the rook
and then c2 now i still have a perpetual
i can take a perpetual here now would
you take the perpetual
you tell me would you take a perpetual
here
white to move would you take the
perpetual check would you move your rook
well of course
yeah you gotta be careful if you move
this rook because this rook is connected
to this rook so if you move this rook
you know maybe somewhere else well you
lose this rook and if you move it up
well then you're allowing a queen
so what are you gonna do what are you
gonna do why to move
here it is guys hope you're ready for
this one okay white said
we're not taking a draw okay you're not
gonna win
and your counterplay not working not
working here it is
work at four for the score shut the door
that's a wrap that's over wait what what
do you mean and actually what black did
this is so strange right
i mean not strange of course there's no
way out of this but the funny thing is
is this is what leela chest did lila
chest took on f2
you know this is the engine moves were
they like oh it's mating four
maiden five why because of the moves
that the engine makes
that don't make any sense to just stop
your mate for longer prolonging the mate
queen takes f2 and what do you do right
that's just not a move well why is rick
f4 so
strong like why don't i just take the
rook and queen that's mean
well watch this nasty move i hope you
did your puzzle rush today
tactics win games bam rick fates on the
board oh my goodness that is
ridiculous king takes and then you would
think it'd be this check but
how many pieces does it take for a
successful attack remember
sometimes in the attacks we use the
pawns as pieces
yeah it's a pun but we're using if you
think about this three one
two and three for a successful attack
work at fate and we great
oh and that's me queen e8 gg start a new
one so
that was it in fact after rick f4 the
only move well this was the move that
was chosen by leelitch at zero
was queen takes f2 check ouch and then
after rook takes
rook g4 for the score i don't know what
score and then rook f7
rook takes h4 not a move g takes taking
on d1
and q87 mates wow
man what am what a positional game and
something to learn from here
as you know you have to be patient
sometimes you got to move pieces around
and you have to maneuver and again the
pawn breaks that's what it takes in
close positions like this one
well i hope you enjoyed today's video
i'm national master james canty the
third here with chess.com
and i'll see you guys on the next video
[Music]
you